(clip) J'plane sur Hyrule,
J'tourne comme un vautour
Comme un russe sur YouTube
J'escalade les tours
On m'a pas donné d'voix
J'communique qu'en sous-titré
Mais des fois (Mais des fois !),
J'fais des onomatopées !
On est aujourd'hui sur le tournage de mon nouveau clip
ça parle de Zelda...Notamment l'opus
BTW (Breath of The Wild) mais pas que !
PUTAIN ! Merde ! OK LE FAIL ! Ah oui, problème majeur
je... j'ai des cheveux dans la bouche et dans le visage...
Et euh... Ca casse mon visage quoi
J'pourrais être n'importe qui en dessous ça pourrait être
Euh...SQUEEZIE, il serait pareil !
"Salut Spock".. Le mec...
On me prend pour Spock !
Ca veut dire que soit il connaît pas Zelda soit  mon costume est totalement mal fait !
(Norman imite Spock) : Je sauve l'espace et j'arrive !
Quelqu'un me recoud l'entre jambe...
C'est... c'est très malaisant hein...le malaise est total !
(une femme) : A toi !
(John Rachid ) : Ah bah ouais, voilà ! le papillon...
*rire* Norman : A toi du coup !
DIX ANS ! DIX ANS DE METIER ! *rire*
*rire* La lourdeur de l'homme !
On m'appelle John John Mc Leon !
-C'est pas hyper impressionnant..
-C'est pas hyper impressionnant, c'est vrai !
j'veux pas te blesser, c'est pour ça que je vais doucement !
(clip) J'm'appelle pas Zelda...(da da da da)
Mon nom ils le connaissent même pas... (pas pas)
*accent russe* J'ai très content de tourner dans tournage de Norman !
*Accent encore russe* Norman a grande chaîne YouTube sur la Russie !
Ah ouais, c'est moi merde ! J'vous dit...
Le passage PNL
TUE SA MERE
"J'veux l'faire"
(Norman) : Pour moi Johns c'est le meilleur comédien de France.. J'ai fait "OK"
T'façon j'fait rien d'autre, j'ai, j'ai l'droit de chanter non ? *chante*
*Johns chante en espagnol*
Hum, j'vous rappelle que chaque colis abandonnés seront considérés comme suspect
On enchaîne, on enchaîne !
Superbe avancé Pedro, super !
*music*
*Noman imite Link avec ses onomatopées*
Ca c'est les fameuses onomatopées de Link
Mais quand je les fais ça fait très con. C'est ça le principe...
Bah,  j'ai perdu un parie etttt...
*rire* Je vais devoir faire le faux Link, donc enfilé...
Cette magnifique tenue
OK ON Y VA LES GARS !
*boing*
*tape sur le bouclier*
*rire* Et comment tu t'appelles ?
*Rire*
Norman : Tes parents sont venus dans la salle ?
Jacques Martin !
Norman : Quesque tu vas nous chanter?
Z-Zelda..
Aller c'est partie !
(clip) J'suis un cordon bleu,
J'cuisine comme un chef,
J'fais des plats douteux,
Sponso MasterChef, j'te met quoi ?
Un lézard ou deux?
Pour ce qui connaissent le jeu, ça c'est LE chaudron
Qu'on utilise quand on veut faire de la cuisine.. quand on veut se préparer des plats
Ca respecte totalement les dimensions du jeu !
Mais pas totalement les dimensions de mon estomac
Voilà, on a installé le décor, tout est absolument parfait
pour faire la scène de Zelda, sauf a un détail près...
Y'a le pêcheur, il veut pas aller pêcher 5 m plus loin !
c'est vraiment SON projet, c'est prendre la truite qu'y'a dans le champs
Gilbert le pêcheur
YES !
J'adore.
Alors ça c'est intéressant, c'est l'arbre officiel du jeu
Même les feuilles sont authentiques, c'est génial
FAUX
Ouais, demain j'suis dispo à 14 ouais
Ouais, c'est ma tablette Sheika.J'passe mes appels, j'envoie des petits textos...
J'arrive !
*Même music que toute a l'heur*
Putain, avec ma peau de babtou
j'vais vraiment devenir écrevisse
Tout rose ! Alors que tout le monde est au soleil, moi je suis en quête
perpétuelle de l'ombre...donc je suis seul, ici..
Sous cette arbuste..
*chuchote* voilà..
Là mon gars, je vais survoler Hyrule ! Mais pour de faux hein
Ca va, j'suis sur un fond vert un peu Américain comme ça
J'AI L'IMPRESSION QUE JE VOLE VRAIMENT
*Attention nouvel musique  ! XD * ( ou alors c'est le suite de le musique de t'al heure XD )
Merci à tous d'avoir regardé ce Making of ! voilà, on a
trop kiffé de faire ce clip c'était vraiment un énorme kiff, si vous
avez apprécié mettez un pouce, allez voire la vidéo si vous l'avez pas déjà vu et puis, on se retrouve
bientôt, pour une prochaine vidéo, et moi j'vais prendre quelques cours d'ocarina parceque là, j'suis pas...j'suis pas au point...*Norman fait de la musique avec son Ocarina, mais il joue pas très bien...AH MES OREILLES !!!!*
Norman : J'ai.. y'a, y'a un début hein...
POUCE BLEU, C'EST LA TRIFORCE
C'EST LA TRIFORCE OUAIS ABONNE TOI
POUCE BLEU, C'EST LA TRIFORCE, C'EST LA TRIFORCE OUAIS ABONNE TOI
POUCE BLEU,
C'EST LA TRIFORCE,
OUAIS ABONNE TOI ! :)
Sous titres par Light (mes premiers sous titres pour Norman !!) Et correction de Megasupergun :)